yeah so you know it's still early days
um right to say that but we are getting
more data enough to start making some
informed Getters this is all the 230
councils uh up for grabs starting to get
colored in a lot more obviously with uh
red blue and yellow but also in Gray
that's no overall control uh Sam talking
about that um so and the big names in
there as well Plymouth Stoke on Trend
and we can see what it's starting to
look like in terms of the geography of
all of this because you know we talk
about all these regions and they are
important this is what it looked like
before this set of Elections this is the
live map now um we have been talking
before about you know around the teas
Valley how that used to be a labor
stronghold four out of five of those
they lost that in 2019 can they get it
back still waiting on those results one
of them has been no overall control but
starting to see it around the rest of
the country and one of the surprising
things looking at it so far is where the
swing by region is happening so if you
are taking a look at where those gains
are being made rather than the North or
Midlands or the East actually the south
is pretty proving very good for labor in
terms of that head-to-head swing from
conservative to labor and that's what
you get in places like Plymouth
obviously if we go and have a look at
that so that was the first labor gain
um from sorry that was a labor gain from
uh no overall control you can see the
results there this shows the historic
vote share for major parties in local
elections over time you can see it's
been fairly fairly even all the way
through and you just get it nosing up
just at the end here and that's the sort
of story we've seen everywhere even if
it's not you know a headline sort of
council taking now to Russia this is
actually a conservative hole but again
you've got that red line creeping up
over there or you know go somewhere else
we'll go to Hartley pool I think
um again look at this this was actually
a very narrow uh remained I don't know
overall control labor came close to
taking that they put on seats but also
again they've stayed above the
conservative and that's a recent search
and that is important because you know
we've been speaking about this a while
but if you're looking at this is the
share of local government votes labor
becomes the biggest party of local
government before it becomes the party
of national government in 1997 the
conservatives do the same thing in 2010
before the formation of the coalition
government and it hasn't happened today
but if you repeat those sorts of crafts
we're seeing with that labor vote just
edging up above the blue well that would
make for a very happy night for kirstama
indeed and being able to say you know
look we are the alternative government
we're ready to take over